[Music]
my name is dr lauren schwartz i am a
clinical neuropsychologist at st
louis university in around 2014
the chess foundation graciously provided
the university a grant to investigate
an interesting research question that
the club had
and so after that point in time they
graciously funded a research endeavor to
look at memory
and chess playing we are looking at
older adults
ages 65 and older who have experienced
some memory loss but that their
day-to-day functioning is still intact
and the question that the chess
foundation wanted to know is if
learning chess when you have memory
problems can slow down
or help with those problems in some way
so we've been
actively recruiting for the study since
approximately 2014
but each participant devotes two years
of time to being in the study
preliminary results we have on the
neuroimaging data
which has shown interestingly that
individuals have experienced an
increase in the thickness of their brain
cells in what's called the temporal
parietal area of the brain
in the left side of their brain which
that area is responsible for things such
as
visual spatial processing and aspects of
memory
so that preliminary finding is very
exciting
so stay tuned though for the
neurocognitive data
so interestingly there isn't a whole lot
of information specific to chest and
that's why we're exciting
because chess is such a unique game in
all of the cognitive skills that it
requires it requires working memory
it requires short-term memory visual
spatial planning
reasoning skills so the the complexity
of the cognitive skills that go into
chess
are very unique a lot of the other
studies have looked at things like
crossword puzzles word searches that
kind of stuff so clearly
while beneficial to a certain degree not
as complex as the game of chess
and so really it it recruits lots of
aspects of brain functioning which makes
it so
interesting and so potentially that
could be what is helpful to our patients
what we're hopeful is that that we do
see either
we could hopeful would be two things one
would be that there are some
improvements of aspects of cognition
in our chess players over time but in my
business
another thing that is equally important
is stability of cognitive skills over
time because we know that
oftentimes memory problems can be
progressive and so if we see
stability across the years that the
participants are in the study
that would also be a positive finding
for us there have not been
this large scale of carefully designed
investigations that
include neuropsychological so cognitive
testing in conjunction
with neuroimaging so we're really
bringing to the table
functional and anatomical data
to answer the question if chess helps
when we have memory loss
i think another unique aspect to this
study is that
they're learning chess in two ways it's
live chess play
so there's that psychosocial component
to the study so maybe helping improve
mood socialization but then they're also
playing on a tablet
so they're getting two aspects of the
knowledge which we're hoping
will be beneficial for this population i
i view this as another recommendation
for physicians and other memory care
providers to be able to give to patients
that there's no risks associated with it
it would be wonderful to be able to
provide another lifestyle
modifiable thing that people really can
work on to help improve
their memory functioning you know we
don't have medicaid many medications in
our arsenal right now to help with this
so
i'm always of the opinion let's throw as
many things at the memory loss problem
as we can
and if if we get great results with this
this is a low stakes thing for people to
be willing to try you know there's not a
medication side effects associated with
playing chess
you know so that would be really great
to be able to offer that as another
thing for patients
once we get covid behind us i think it
would be really great to get
both tablets into for example some of
the independent living communities
some of the skilled nursing homes and
then also live chess play for them as
well i think that you know
when folks are not able to interact the
computer piece is really great
but bringing people together that's the
one thing that we really have seen with
this study is that
that in that that human interaction
playing this game that
frustrates and encourages them all at
the same time has just been great
there's been friendships made in the
study so getting it out into the
communities i think would have to be a
two-prong approach
bringing education into senior centers
and then also
teaching them how to do it by themselves
on a computer platform
but then having groups so that they can
get together i think that's the most
important piece that human interaction
i think that um the most important thing
that i'd like to say is one thank you
to the chess foundation for the
opportunity to get to embark on a study
like this that has never been done
before
but i would certainly be remiss not to
thank
all of the hard-working individuals that
participated in getting this off the
ground and running it on the day-to-day
so my co-investigator is dr ted malstrom
our research nurse coordinator is susan
brown our research assistant is tom
malone
and we have a numerous other
neuropsychologists in the building that
have been
actively recruiting patients from their
clinics but
the people that i named really are are
the core members of the team